deandra first off how are you we're
about a month
out since you were hospitalized for
covent how are you doing
yes i'm doing much better thank you
bryce for asking i'm glad to be on the
other side of it for sure
i'm you know back to almost almost back
to my old self
that's very good to hear all right well
we are in the thick of season five
how are you feeling about this season
i'm feeling good
i'm excited to tell a different story
with a different um shows a different
side of my personality
shows my ability to be compassionate
because you a lot of people are you know
wondering if i had the ability to be
compassionate for years so
they'll see that i think this season of
rhod
you've got just every element of great
storytelling because we were
forced to be very introspective you're
at home you're dealing with all these
things and you've got a camera in your
face
which that also makes for really
interesting tv because you can't run you
can't hide this year
it seems that removing one element from
the show
from the group leanne lochen maybe freed
you up
in a sense do you feel like that yes it
definitely freed me up i think the way i
handled maybe some of the situations
with liam if i look back
i would have handled them differently i
would have come and said you hurt my
feelings when you talked about the
situation with my finances because i was
trying to save my business instead of
being so
angry but i was just in a state of shock
back then
this year i get to talk about other
things than you know leah and i not
getting along which is great and i think
right
exciting do you have any sort of
relationship with her anymore or is it
kind of
we've parted ways wish the best on her
journey
i do not have a relationship with her we
do not see eye to eye on several things
and
the social media got so out of hand that
i just can't go back to
a friendship when things were said about
me that were complete
lies and it's not that i can't forgive
because i have to forgive
but it's just why go back and take a
chance
i wish her well i'm so glad that she and
rich are happy and that she's got other
things she's doing in her life and just
happy for
all of her endeavors i like it very
diplomatic
uh dr tiffany moon we all have to thank
you for bringing this woman
into our lives into our homes i mean the
fan response has been
wild were you expecting the audience to
respond to tiffany in the way that they
have
i knew that she would be well liked
because she has a wonderful personality
she's very opinionated she has that
je ne sais quoi she's just the whole
package
yeah like i said the audience has fallen
in love with her it seems like
some of the women uh at least not what
we've seen yet
they did not fall in love with tiffany
why do you think that is i don't know
bryce and it's interesting to see when
we get to her union what people say
because i will be interested to see
what happens there i really don't know
what the issue is i think that
she has had a huge splash and i think
that's a part of it and
whereas i look at it and like big win
people are paying
attention to rhod this is amazing you
know it's like great we've got
this new housewife that's bringing all
this attention and people are really
noticing our franchise and they're
seeing what we can bring to the table
and for me i'm thinking this is the best
thing ever and i keep calling them like
oh my god girl you are winning you are
doing great thank you so much you know
and i can understand that where people
would think maybe there was a little
jealousy or a little bit
um you know not what they expected i
guess
people don't like change that's that's
the big lesson is i think people don't
like change
we also have another newbie this year
jen davis there were rumors that you two
had some sort of like knockout drag out
fight
uh did you and will we see that
i don't you know if you didn't see it it
didn't happen let's put it that way
if you didn't see it wasn't there uh now
last year you
introduced carrie brittingham to this
group yes
something seems to have shifted between
seasons four and five between the two of
you
what changed why has this friendship
started
to fizzle it seems yeah bryce i am still
confused about that to be honest um i
didn't understand
that carrie had such deep seated
opinions and feelings about our
friendship
until i started watching the season i
mean i knew we were fighting a lot
um on you know during filming but i
never
ever would have thought that she would
have called me selfish or that i wasn't
a good friend or any of the things that
she's saying about me and
it really hurt my feelings um and i
really have tried to get to the bottom
of it with her
and you'll see that kind of unpack and
unfold that
i don't know there's a bee in her bonnet
as we like to say in the south and i
don't know what set it off
it does look like there's an emotional
moment where you sit face to face with
her and
open up to her i may not be the type of
friend that you
expect but i'm doing the best i can what
leads us to that moment
after hearing a lot about what she's
going through
and the different struggles she's had
i thought well maybe i should be a
little more compassionate or a little
more understanding and that's really my
journey this year anyway
so i i really sat with darren my shaman
and
talked through it with him and how could
i you know maybe
kind of change change the way she
reacted to me by not being so
reactionary to her by kind of like
catching her off guard with
being the person to come to the table
and say okay i'm sorry if i haven't been
a good friend but let's figure this out
and let me try to be a better friend
got it the shaman you are on this
journey with him it seems
but why was he sucking a booger out of
your nose deandra
was not sucking anything out of my nose
it is so funny that people think he was
sucking
he was blowing it's an amazonian sacred
tobacco
into my nose and so it gives you kind of
a euphoric
light feeling makes you relax and calm
down
and de-stress and it's a very nice kind
of
you know zen moment
okay so i think it was maybe a an added
sound effect
there that gave people the idea that he
was sucking out
who would want to suck a booger oh god
well that's what i was like what
journey is this but the shaman is
helping you figure out
kind of this struggle you're having with
the other half of your family half
brother stepmother
um will will we see a a conclusion to
that journey or are you still on it
um you kind of will see um
i can't really answer that question it's
kind of an ongoing story
but we see them at all your stepmother
half i can't tell you that
oh my gosh how you are going to get me
in so much trouble
i think we can read between the lines
there though
there is still a lot of season left to
watch
uh what are you most excited for the
fans to get to see in season five
well they'll see a lot of drama again
from me and conflict
but i think as you noted with carrie
you'll see how i
uh resolve that conflict which is i
believe
in my heart different than in prior
seasons and that is the beauty
of this process and being on this
journey every year is that you get to
do it all over again and have a redo and
show a different side of yourself if you
want to
and this year for me when the camera
started rolling
is when my stepmother had reached out to
me that first week
that's why we told that story i wasn't
and i mean i had been thinking about it
for a long time
but i really wasn't kind of prepped and
ready
and i said i remember i said i've got to
my husband i said i've got to tell the
story it's happening right now
he said are you sure you want to do this
i said yes because this is what's really
going on in my life and this is a
reality show and so i'm very
happy that we were able to tell that
story i love it you
it's kind of flipping the negative into
a positive i asked you what you're most
looking forward to and you
said the hard parts it sounds like the
hard parts exactly because those are the
times of growth for me personally
and you're gonna see kind of a more more
vulnerable definitely more
vulnerable uh side than you've ever seen
before
i'm excited um your tagline
your your reading of your tagline crap
oh my lord every week
me too dallas girls are sugar and spice
but i'm still working on nice every time
i listen i'm like oh when did my voice
get that low
it sounds like you just took like a big
drag of a cigarette and you're like let
me tell you
oh my gosh i don't know what happened i
didn't even know that my voice was that
low that register
so it was kind of it was a shock to me
too but i had
several i think reads of that line and
um you know that's the one they chose
and
it certainly surprised people they're
like wait what is that jello squirrels
are shooting
us and um still working out nice
it brings me joy every episode i love it
i love it you like it
[Music]